Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Well actually, we're done.
It's been kind of a long road, but
we just covered a bunch of material.
I apologize if I talk too much.
I do that and
my kids tell me that all the time.
But i think you got a bunch of good
grounding on the fundamentals of
Computer Vision.
We manipulated images as functions,
everything from frequency content
to talking about filtering.
We talked about how cameras and camera
models work that allow you to reason
about the geometry
between multiple views.
We talked about finding features in one
image, and how you would find them in
another image, so
that you could relate them, either for
doing image manipulation, doing for
recognition, or just doing the geometry.
We talked a little bit about image
formation, in terms of how light
interplays with material in order
to make a picture to begin with.
We talked about how in video
images change and, and
the motion happens in doing tracking.
Then towards the end, we focused a bit
more on recognition, classification.
And we talked about how to do sort
of more serious work in that area,
you would have to know more
about machine learning.
And in fact, that's a good
sort of jumping off point for
where you might go from here.
If you actually wanted to do some
high-end work in computer vision
involving recognition,
classification, labelling,
you probably would have to get well
grounded in machine learning methods.
At least, grounded enough that you
could understand the methods that
are currently being applied.
There's another side, in fact,
one of the other Udacity Georgia Tech
courses on computational photography,
which thinks about the manipulation of
images with respect to creating new
images, or thinking about it sort
of an advanced media perspective.
And in particular, even though this
feels like a somewhat comprehensive
course in computer vision, if you were
to sort of go out there and you know,
try to do work in
a computer vision world,
there are some things you'll
see that you didn't see.
We were very, shall we say, careful in
many of the images that we gave you.
Images are much less well-behaved
than the images that we gave you.
And one of the first things
you find out is that wow,
I wasn't getting the types of
images that I was expecting, and so
you have to think a lot more about how
you get the images to be the way you
want them to be, and
then in order to do the computer vision.
The flip side is consuming the
information that comes out of computer
vision, all right?
Is that going to go into some system
that's going to do more reasoning
about the nature of what's going on?
Are you going to set off alarms?
Are you going to mark things?
Are you going to go shopping?
What's going to be the output,
how's that output going to be used?
So, I'm sure at this point,
you feel like you've learned some stuff.
There is a lot more to do, but
a lot of what needs to be done is really
the applications of these basic skills,
to sort of the specific set of
imagery that you're working with.
So, I hope you will do some of that.
If you do and it works well,
please send us a note.
I love it when I hear
students come back and say,
you know,
I I thought your class was okay.
It's kind of a lot of work.
But man, am I glad I took it,
because I'm now doing this sort of
imagery analysis of aerial imagery, and
all of a sudden I find myself
using stuff that we learned.
So if you have any of those experiences,
please share them with us, with me.
And we look forward to
talking to you again.
Bye.